tras 18 días de paro en ecuador llegó la
imagen de la firma entre la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas conaie y el gobierno un
acuerdo celebrado ya que pone fin a una
de las mayores crisis del gobierno de
guillermo lasso pero que detrás ha
tenido duras negociaciones hemos
alcanzado el valor supremo al que todos
aspiramos más en nuestro país terminó el
paro ahora empezamos juntos la tarea de
transformar esta paz en progreso
bienestar y oportunidades para todos en
el acta los dos lados han tenido que
ceder en sus puntos la conaie aceptó una
rebaja de 15 centavos en lugar de 40 al
precio del combustible el principal
factor del inicio de las protestas
aunque consiguió derogar un decreto que
promovía la actividad petrolera en la
amazonía y condonar deudas inferiores a
tres mil dólares que tengan familias
campesinas victorias parciales que no
contentaron a algunos líderes indígenas
y mantuvieron la tensión durante horas
aunque al final fueron aceptadas a
través de su líder leonidas iza por
pacificar el país
y acceder al y garantizar el reto de
puntos que si hemos jugado compañeras y
con esto las protestas que han
paralizado al ecuador durante 15 días
cesarán el gobierno tiene un plazo de 90
días para cumplir lo pactado pero si no
llegaran a hacerlo la conaie ha
amenazado con volver a salir a las
calles